yes the National Space Biomedical
Research Institute was created about
let's see I think it's about 12 years
ago by NASA and it was looking for a way
to kind of fund our final research
dollars through this Institute to go out
and collaborate with universities and
other research institutes in a way that
NASA would have more difficult to doing
because NASA is a government agency and
so it created and run by the baylor
college of medicine and i was hired on
Oh probably about let's see I guess it's
been about three years and I'm the
chairman of the user committee your user
panel and what we are we're a panel
composed of current next former
astronauts as well as current and former
flight surgeons and what we do is we
advise the Chairman we're invite an
advisory panel we advise the chairman on
the research projects that we think are
operationally relevant that is what do
we need to what do we need to learn
about and what do we need to develop a
protocol for to deal with a medical
problem in space so as an example one of
the biggest concerns about going out
beyond low-earth orbit is the radiation
you know we can we find that exercise
seems to counteract a lot of the
negative effects of spaceflight like
bone loss and and muscle atrophy and
cardiovascular systems you know issues
but really the radiation is something
you worry about if you get start going
on a trip to Mars you're going to be
away from the Van Allen belts you're
going to be susceptible to solar flares
and what do you do and so that's one of
our big areas of concerns and so we see
the US advising the director for the NS
Bri that well we should fund more
research on developing better detectors
or better or pharmaceutical
countermeasures maybe to help protect
astronauts from from radiation or even
looking at shielding you know what kind
of lightweight shielding would be most
effective to to create safe haven in a
spacecraft going to Mars other areas of
research as I mentioned were bone loss
and muscle loss and cardiovascular
atrophy those are always significant
areas that were worried about now
exercises I said seems to counteract a
lot of that but right now we exercise
two hours a day on the station which is
a huge hit out of your day I mean it's
great for staying in shape but you know
it cuts into the productivity of the
crew
and and you if you look at how expensive
it is to get a crew into space if we can
keep them healthy but and have them
exercise but you know spend less time
doing it we can get more done
well it's it's very important first of
all if you if you think about it
especially on a long flight like a
six-month space flight and on the ISS if
you didn't exercise in you know use the
analogy honor if you'd be like laying in
bed so just imagine laying in bed for
several months and even just trying to
get up and walk you probably wouldn't be
able to but if you got up and you
exercised two hours a day he'd probably
be okay and that's the same in space the
exercises we do we do cardiovascular and
resistance exercises and so we have a
treadmill but of course we have
harnesses and rubber bungees to hold us
down to the track so that we don't float
away we have exercise bicycles and we
also have a resistive exercise device
that uses loaded chords that we can vary
the resistance on and you can attach a
bar or harness to these chords and do
weight lifting type exercises so that
helps keep your bones and your muscles
in shape
well one of the ultrasound experiments
that we did on board was very
interesting we were doing something
called telemedicine where we were using
the ultrasound and I'm not an MD neither
was my my crewmate on board but we were
able to with very little training show
that we could produce diagnostic quality
images of Bones eyes internal organs
things like that and so one interesting
application of this ultrasound is the
possibility that you could actually use
it to measure critical bone areas or
areas where we know historically have
seen a lot of loss and you could
actually track during a long space
mission do measurements and track if
you're losing bone in these areas so
that's something that's very exciting
because on earth when they check you for
for boneless you get in this big machine
I mean it's huge it's the size of a room
and it's got a platform with an xray
that kind of scans your whole body and
in there in critical areas and it takes
takes a while and it just wouldn't be
practical to have a machine like that in
space so if you could show that using a
portable diagnostic quality ultrasound
which basically is the size of a laptop
with you know some extensions to it if
you could actually measure reliably bone
loss with that that would be a great
tool to have
well there's some very exciting work in
that area and one of the researchers is
funded by NS Bri is working on exactly
that and that has real application
because when you're monitoring an
astronaut we're not always monitored but
during certain times when we're having a
physical exam you know we have to take
blood samples or we have to give other
samples and it's you know it's not easy
to do especially in zero gravity you
know so can you can imagine trying to
squeeze blood out of a finger prick and
then getting a new capillary tube and
getting that into a machine to be
analyzed you know it all can be done and
we do it but it's you know then you've
got you might have some droplets of
blood floating around you know so if you
can find a non-invasive way to do it
that would certainly make life easy for
us on board also when you're in a space
suit you know we do some very
rudimentary monitoring right now in both
the Russian in the u.s. space suits we
load up a simple electrocardiogram and
thus flight surgeons can look at the you
know your your heartbeat while you're
doing the spacewalk they can also well
they don't have it right now but they
could also theoretically look at maybe
with this device the oxygenation of your
blood and other parameters just to
determine the health of the astronaut
who's doing the spacewalk so this kind
of technology is very exciting and has
real application in space and the neat
thing about a lot of the antis Bri
projects that are funded by NS Bri is
they also have application for patients
on the ground the ultrasound that I
mentioned it has application not only in
space for a long mission or for a
mission of the Moon or Mars but also in
remote areas on the earth you know not
even just and I'm not even talking about
expeditions like to the Antarctic but
just a remote area a small town
somewhere you know the local doctor is
not going to know everything and so if
that person can link in with a
diagnostic ultrasound to the hospital in
New York City you know through the
internet then we can do a very quick
diagnosis of something that's wrong with
someone who's in this remote area
well if you ask astronauts will tell you
there's no issue you know but of course
fatigue is a problem it's as big a
problem in space that as it is on the
ground and you could make an argument
that it's even more critical in space
because a mistake up there could be
literally life-threatening or could
cause you know big problems in the
mission so fatigue is an issue that
we're concerned about we're definitely
scheduled for full eight hours of sleep
every night but just like on earth
you're always you're often busy and you
don't you know usually don't use all
that eight hours to sleep you're usually
staying up late and catching up on
things you're doing something you want
to do you know looking at your
photographs or or watching a movie or
something and so over time over a long
mission fatigue can really build up and
that's something that we are trained as
astronauts to be self-aware of you know
we have to kind of monitor ourselves but
we also have tools and some of which are
also funded by NS PRI we have self self
assessment tools computer-based tools to
see if we're how we're performing
mentally and there's some also very
interesting technology and work that's
being funded by NS bri to look at facial
recognition to look at your patterns to
see if you're experiencing stress or
fatigue I find that interesting and i
have to tell you as an astronaut it
makes me a little bit concerned because
as an operator I could see getting up
there and thinking well okay now I've
got to control my facial muscles to make
sure that they don't think I'm stressed
out you know but really it's it's a kind
of thing that I think will gain
acceptance with gradually you know but
it probably has more immediate
application in things like homeland
security and you know looking at facial
recognition of people going through
airports and things like that to see
who's under stress